♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HERE IS A QUICK CIVICS
LEGISLATIVE.
WHAT IS POLITICS?
POLITICS IS A SYSTEM THAT
ALLOWS PEOPLE WHO VIOLENTLY
DISAGREE WITH EACH OTHER TO
REACH COMPROMISE WITHOUT
SHEDDING BLOOD.
IT'S WORKED WELL FOR A LONG
TIME IN THIS COUNTRY.
BUT WHEN ONE SIDE DECIDES IT
IS NO LONGER WILLING TO
COMPROMISE, THAT SYSTEM
BREAKS DOWN.
WITHOUT COMPROMISE YOU NO
LONGER HAVE POLITICS.
INSTEAD HAVE YOU AN
ESPECIALLY FANATICAL FORM OF
RELIGIOUS BELIEF.
ISIS, FOR EXAMPLE, IS NOT A
POLITICAL ORGANIZATION.
ITS LEADERS REJECT
ACCOMMODATION OF ANY KIND.
ITS LEADERS ASSUME THAT
EVERYTHING THEY DO HAS THE
APPROVAL OF A HIGHER POWER.
THEY ARE GOOD PEOPLE.
THEY KNOW THAT THEY KNOW
THEIR BELIEFS ARE NOT SIMPLY
CORRECT THEY ARE THE ONLY
POSSIBLE BELIEFS.
ANYONE WHO DISAGREES WITH
THEM IS BY DEFINITION
IMMORAL.
A SYSTEM LIKE THAT DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR THE POSSIBILITY
THAT GOOD PEOPLE MIGHT BE
MISTAKEN ONCE IN A WHILE OR
REACH DIFFERENT CONCLUSIONS
SINCERELY.
PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT
OPINIONS ARE, AGAIN BY
DEFINITION, BAD PEOPLE.
IN FACT, MAY NOT BE PEOPLE
AT ALL THEY MIGHT BE
SUBHUMAN.
THEY MUST BE CONVERT YOU HAD
TO THE FAITH OR CRUSHED AND
ELIMINATED THIS IS NOT AN
AMERICAN WAY OF LOOKING AT
THE WORLD AND YET, SUDDENLY,
IT'S EVERYWHERE.
UNFORTUNATELY NOW DEFINES
PARTS OF THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T KNOW.
THIS BIDEN HAS BEEN THE
DEMOCRATIC POLITICS ALL OF
HIS LIFE.
HE HAS TAKEN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS OFF.
FLYING AROUND THE WORLD
GETTING RICH BY GIVING HIGH
PRICE SPEECHES.
BY THE TIME BIDEN DECIDED HE
WANTED TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
YET AGAIN, HIS PARTY HAD
COMANGED COMPLETELY.
NOBODY HAD TOLD HIM.
HE MADE THE MISTAKE THE
OTHER DAY ABOUT SAYING THIS
ABOUT MIKE PENCE.
>> THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS, FOLLOWED ON BY A GUY IS
A DECENT GUY.
OUR VICE PRESIDENT.
WHO STOOD BEFORE THIS GROUP
OF ALLIES AND LEADERS AND
SAID I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP THERE WAS
DEAD SILENCE, DEAD SILENCE.
>> Tucker: IS HE A DECENT
GUY, BIDEN SAID OF PENCE.
THAT'S AN OLD FASHIONED WAY
TO TALK.
THAT'S HOW PEOPLE IN
POLITICAL WASHINGTON USED TO
TALK ABOUT EACH OTHER.
IT WAS ONE WAY THAT THEY
REMINDED THEMSELVES POLITICS
IS IMPORTANT BUT IT'S NOT
EVERYTHING.
EVERY POLITICAL OPPONENT IS
ALSO ON SOME LEVEL ANYWAY A
HUMAN BEING AND A FELLOW
AMERICAN.
OUR COMMON HUMANITY IS
STRONGER THAN OUR POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES.
THAT WAS THE ASSUMPTION THAT
THEY HAD AND HAVE HAD SINCE
THE CIVIL THE ASSUMPTION WE
HAVE TO HAVE IF WE ARE GOING
TO LIVE IN THE SAME COUNTRY.
NIXON FORMER ACTOR AND NOW A
POLITICAL EXTREMIST.
SPENDS A LOT OF TIME ON
TWITTER YELLING AT PEOPLE.
SHE WAS ENRAGED.
CYNTHIA NIXON DISAGREES WITH
MIKE PENCE'S VIEWS ON GAY
RIGHTS QUESTION.
THEREFORE SHE KNOWS PENCE
CANNOT BE A DECENT PERSON.
IT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE.
SHE TOLD JOE BIDEN THIS ON
TWITTER.
JOE BIDEN HAD NO CHOICE BUT
TO AGREE WITH HER YOU ARE
RIGHT, CYNTHIA, BIDEN WROTE
BACK.
THERE IS NOTHING DECENT
ABOUT BEING ANTI-LBGTQ RIGHT
AND THAT INCLUDES THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE USE TO SAY JOE BIDEN
WADst WAS A DECENT GUY
TOO.
ONLY THOSE WITH THE PROGRAM
AND APPOSE TATES WHO DEVIATE
FROM IT TULSI GAB GUARD IN
THE LATER.
SHE IS A STAUNCH
PROGRESSIVE.
SHE DOES HOLD HETERO DOCKS
OPINIONS WITH.
THIS DOESN'T BILL KRISTOL.
SHE AGREES SHE WANTS TO KEEP
THE U.S. OUT OF POINTLESS
FOREIGN CONFLICTS AND
INSTEAD FOCUS ON DOMESTIC
CONCERNS.
FOR HAVING THAT OPINION SHE
HAS ALMOST BEEN EXPELLED
FROM HER OWN PARTY.
WATCH.
>> THEY HAVE DISMISSED YOU
FOR SUCKING UP TO DICTATOR
BAD PERSON BASICALLY WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING.
HAS ANYBODY ACTUALLY DEBATED
YOU ON THE POINTS THAT YOU
ARE MAKING?
>> NO.
NO.
CONSTANTLY I SEE AGAIN
PEOPLE FROM BOTH PARTIES,
INSTEAD, RESORTING TO
NAME-CALLING OR SUPERFICIAL
ATTACKS BECAUSE THEY REFUSE
TO ENGAGE ON THE SUBSTANCE
OF THIS ARGUMENT ABOUT WHY
THEY CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
AND TRY TO WAGE THESE REGIME
CHANGE WARS, IGNORING THE
DISASTROUS CONSEQUENCES ON
THE PEOPLE IN THOSE
COUNTRIES AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO THAT SUDDENLY
IS A VERY CONTROVERSIAL
THING TO SAY IN THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
A PLACE WHERE THERE IS NO
ROOM FOR DISSENT ANYWHERE ON
ANY ISSUE.
ON WEDNESDAY, FOR EXAMPLE,
HANDFUL OF DEMOCRATS JOINED
WITH REPUBLICANS TO ADD AN
AMENDMENT TO A UNIVERSAL
BACKGROUND CHECKS BILL IN
THE HOUSE.
THAT AMENDMENT WOULD REQUIRE
REPORTING OF GUN BUYERS TO
ICE IF THAT BUYER IS AN
ILLEGAL ALIEN.
A GROUP THAT IS NOT ALLOWED
TO BUY GUN NOTICE UNITED
STATES.
IN A CLOSED DOOR MEETING
AFTER THE VOTE, THE
DEMOCRATS WHO JOINED WITH
REPUBLICANS ON THAT WERE
REPORTEDLY DENOUNCED BY
PARTY LEADERSHIP FOR THEIR
RACISM.
THE PARTY'S NEW IDEOLOGICAL
ENFORCER ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ WARNED THAT
DEMOCRATS WHO HELPED
REPUBLICANS IN ANY WAY WOULD
GO ON A QUOTE RISK AND WOULD
HAVE PRIMARY CHALLENGES NEXT
TIME THEY RAN THAT'S WHAT
EXTREMISM LOOKS LIKE THE
ENEMY IS 100 PERCENT WRONG
AND WE ARE 100 PERCENT RIGHT
ALWAYS THEY ARE GOING TO
HELL AND WE ARE SAFE.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS
A SIN AGAINST GOD.
I BELIEVE THAT.
>> JESUS SAID SUFFER THE
LITTLE CHILDREN UNTO ME.
HE DID NOT SAY LET THE
CHILDREN SUFFER.
>> A TIME IN WHICH WE
CELEBRATE THE BIRTH OF JESUS
CHRIST, THANK GOD THAT THERE
WASN'T A WALL THAT STOPPED
HIM FROM SEEKING REFUGE IN
EGYPT.
THANK GOD THAT WALL WASN'T
THERE AND THANK GOD THERE
WASN'T AN ADMINISTRATION
LIKE.
THIS AND WHILE WE ARE DOING
THE LORD'S WORK BY
MINISTERING TO THE NEEDS OF
GOD'S CREATION, THEY ARE
IGNORING THOSE NEEDS WHICH
IS TO DISHONOR THE GOD WHO
MADE THEM.
>> Tucker: WE ARE DOING
GOD'S WILL AND WE ARE ON
GOD'S SIDE.
GOD LOVES US.
GOD DOES NOT LOVE THE OTHER
SIDE.
THEY ARE SINNERS.
THEY ARE GOING AGAINST GOD'S
WILL.
IN FACT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY COULD BE NAZIS.
>> THIS IS THE UNITED STATES
OF GERMANY.
THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
IT ISN'T NAZI GERMANY.
>> BOTTOM LINE, DONALD TRUMP
INCREASINGLY LOOKS LIKE
HITLER AND NAZI, GERMANY.
>> MUCH LIKE HITLER TOOK
OVER THE NAZI PARTY, TRUMP
HAS TAKEN OVER THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> IF YOU VOTE FOR TRUMP,
THEN YOU, THE VOTER, YOU,
NOT DONALD TRUMP, ARE
STANDING AT THE BORDER LIKE
NAZIS GOING YOU HERE, YOU
HERE.
THEY ARE THE TACTICS BEEN
USED THROUGH HISTORY BY THE
WORST PURVEYORS OF PURE EVIL
INCLUDING SLAVE TRADERS AND
NAZIS AND TERRORISTS.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU ARE
LOOKING AT IS NOT POLITICS
IT'S A CULT.
NUANCES IS THE ENEMY.
ACCOMMODATION IS A SIN.
ASK TOO MANY QUESTIONS OR
THINK TOO MANY INDEPENDENT
THOUGHTS AND YOU WILL BE
DENOUNCED WIND UP ON
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ'S
LIST.
WE REJECT THIS COMPLETELY.
IT'S TOTALITARIAN.
IT'S ALSO STUPID AND BORING.
IT'S A REPLACEMENT FOR
THOUGHT.
BY THE WAY DESTROYING A
COUNTRY AS WELL.
WE WILL ALWAYS WELCOME
PEOPLE WE DISAGREE WITH ON
TO THIS SHOW.
WE ASSUME THEY ARE DECENT
PEOPLE.
MOSTLY THEY ARE DECENT
WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO FIND
COMMON GROUND WITH THEM AND
ANYONE ELSE WHENEVER WE CAN
BECAUSE WHY WOULDN'T WE?
THAT'S WHY YOU WILL OFTEN
SEE SINCERE LEFTIST ON THIS
SHOW TREATED WITH RESPECT.
TULSI GABBARD.
GREEN WALD, MANY OTHERS.
WE DISAGREE WITH THESE
PEOPLE ON A LOT OF THINGS
BUT NOT ON EVERYTHING AND
THAT'S THE POINT.
BUT MOST IMPORTANT OF ALL,